If you've been on the internet for a few years you've probably noticed that
some websites look or act differently on different browsers.
And trying to open a modern website on an older browser sometimes yields
a buggy experience.
Obviously as web developers we want to ensure that our users have
the same awesome experience regardless of their browsers or operating systems.
This has been a problem since the beginning of the web and
there are solutions available to manage cross-browser compatibility.
If you search for
CSS resetting or CSS normalize, you'll run into this style sheet, normalize.css.
Let's take a look at it.
This will help ensure that your CSS styles are interpreted the same
across all browsers.
To take advantage of CSS resetting, simply link to the CSS style you see here,
like so, and
you can be confident that your styles will work the same across all browsers.